Хвостатий борець з контрабандою пес Рамсі заступив на чергування.
В автівках собака полює на цигарки та бурштин.
Молодець! Добре!
За час своєї служби пес виявив найбільшу партію контрабандного каміння.  Понад 300 кілограмів.
Тонкий нюх Рамсі виявляє схованки в найнеочікуваніших місцях.
Якось, наприклад, в акумуляторі автомобіля знайшов цигарки.
Тож, аби збити зі сліду чи задобрити пса, ймовірні порушники,
трапляється, пропонують йому так би мовити собачий "хабар".
Звичайно, пропонують, але ми з Рамсі відмовляємося від такого…
Кісточки можуть, ковбаски… Я не дозволяю.
Бути непідкупним, як Рамсі, вміють на митниці далеко не всі.
Тож кожна нова влада оголошує себе борцем з корупцією.
Тож і команда Володимира Зеленського не стала винятком.
У липні 2019-го президент побував на Закарпатті,
аби заявити про свої наміри побороти корупцію на кордоні.
На митниці, зокрема, очільник країни перевіряв роботу сканувальних систем,
які закупила попередня влада, але так і не запустила…
А де світло, чому немає?
Та поспілкувався із самими митниками.
У Вас який телефон? Айфон? Звідки айфон? Малі зарплати?
Тоді Зеленський закликав усіх, хто не хоче працювати чесно, звільнятися.
Минув рік, і керівництво країни могло б звітувати
про досягнення у боротьбі з контрабандою на кордоні.
Принаймні розрекламовані сканувальні системи на Закарпатській митниці нарешті почали працювати.
Увага! Сканування!
Щоправда, на додаткову перевірку сюди відправляють не всі фури.
Лише порожні - аби переконатися, що ванатажу справді немає.
Або ж ті, які викликали підозри в інспектора.
Система генерує ризики. Наприклад, якщо на водія вже складався протокол.
Якщо раніше були виявлені якісь вкладення,
тоді цей транспортний засіб автоматично потрапляє під ризиковість.
І його направляють на сканування.
З України нелегально вивозять бурштин, деревину та цигарки -
товари, які в Європі коштують значно дорожче.
Натомість в Україну ввозять різноманітну електроніку: комп'ютери, телефони, планшети.
Ще низка контрабандних товарів єтиповими саме для регіону Закарпаття -
це так звані "італійські посилки" від трудових мігрантів -
одяг та взуття відомих брендів. А також продукти харчування.
На початку літа ці автобуси счинили справжній бунт на митниці.
Адже не погоджувались з новими правилами митного оформлення товару.
Ми регламентували порядок роботи з італійськими бусами,
які були основним джерелом для Закарпаття.
Для ділків, які були дотичні до цих схем.
Якщо маєте більше 50 кілограмів, то маєте розмитнити по такій ставці.
І воно запрацювало. Я дякую митникам, що так сталось.
Ті, які нехтують загальними позиціями, ковідом, не розуміючи,
що ми маємо наповнювати сьогодні бюджет, займаються незаконним власним збагаченням.
Але це вже не системно
Найчастіше кожна нова влада бореться саме з такою, дрібною контрабандою,
каже місцевий політолог Максим Шелемба.
А великі контрабандні схеми натомість від виборів до виборів залишаються незмінними.
Бо в регіонах - це виконавці, які схему завершують.
Але вони не є основними. Те, що тут на Закарпатті зміниться, будуть вибори,
це вплине лише на перерозподіл потоків і можливих виконавців,
але основні схеми і діяльність залежить від органів влади в Києві.
Бо в Києві визначають керівників митниці, які знають, як все працює тут, на місці.
І це вигідно не тільки українській державі.
дуже багато з цих схем існує в Угорщині, Румунії, Словаччині.
Бо якщо це контрабанда в бік ЄС, то якщо наші пропустили, чому не зловили угорці чи румуни.
Бо у них так само є на державному рівні певне кришування.
І так само певні мафіозні структури в цьому зацікавлені.
Щороку Україна недоотримує в бюджет до 45 мільярдів гривень через контрабанду.
Ці цифри базуються на підрахунках обігу сірої торгівлі в інтернет-магазинах,
розповідає екскерівник Державної митної служби.
Поборотися можна за ту частину, яка концентрована. Це те, що називається "одеська контрабада", "закарпатська",
великі контрабандні барони, яких називають по імені,
але СБУ і прокуратура чогось їх не бачать і дивляться в інший бік.
Донедавна сам Нефьодов був уособленням очікуваних змін на митниці.
Адже в грудні 2019 року став першим керівником реформованої
Державної митної служби, тобто "нової митниці".
В нову структуру мали б не допустити старі кадри
із сумнівною біографією та причетних до корупційних скандалів.
Натомість звільнили самого Нефьодова - нібито через те, що нова митниця
провалила план з виконання дохідної частини держбюджету.
При мені на Закарпатській митниці десь 50 людей не було переведено в штат.
І це були одіозні співробітники, про яких найбільше повідомлень у пресі.
Це так звана футбольна команда, колишні футболісти групи "Минай",
які чомусь масово працюють митниками.
Цей процес розпочався, людям почали видавати повідомлення про звільнення.
Але коли мене звільнили, цей процес був згорнутий і навіть ті митники,
на яких кричав Зеленський, вони поновлюються назад.
В умовах, коли не проводять розслідування правоохоронні органи,
досліджувати спосіб життя митників беруться журналісти.
Втім, займатись подібними розслідуванням в регіоні небезпечно, каже Олена Мудра.
Вона родом із Закарпаття і обізнана про контрабандні схеми,
в які включені в регіоні всі: від звичайних людей, що працюють так званими "піджаками",
переносячи товар по кілька десятків разів через кордон,  - до чиновників різних рангів.
Стрійчики і Лазорики, вони перейшли в нову службу начальниками постів
заступниками начальників,  начальниками митних змін.
Статки, ви бачили, можна побачити в декларації -
це автівки останніх моделей, це будинки,
квартири і не лише на Закарпатті.
Це бізнес, починаючи від якогось магазину і кафе і до бізнесу за кордоном.
Тобто ці люди - це символи закарпатської митниці і символ того,
що реформа не спрацювала
і що вони зі старої митниці перейшли в нову.
Де беруться кошти на таке майно, питання риторичне.
Адже офіційно зарплата начальника митниці - трохи більше тридцяти тисяч гривень.
У рядових співробітників - в рази менша.
Не знаю на рахунок нашого хабарництва на митниці, але якби були зарплати достойні
на митниці, було б краще. 8-9 тисяч, але не завжди премії є. А так 4-5...
На Закарпатській митниці показник зі збору митних платежів перевиконують.
В липні майже на 120%.
Можливо, для теперішньої влади саме ці цифри,
а не розслідування і посадки і є результатом реформи.